now just gonna pause is there another
thing I could do I could just to learn
it through now just pause for a bit
we could have work at that one okay the
first thing we're point out is so it
dismiss long division in the same way
don't dismiss completing the square
other methods like that okay one of the
reasons why is long division will always
work long division looks at this and
says well it has to be like this is a
factor so therefore this must be another
factor long division is how you can
factor okay
secondly like look at this guy right if
we didn't learn this then you could go
straight to this line and then you be
kind of what else can I do
third is fair would be nice right this
is option one
comparing coefficients let's look at
option two let's see what happens if you
don't define this is what I've got
all right
okay now remember polynomial division
despite the way it looks is actually a
less work at least in my mind it's on
what this work the numerical long
division because in the America long
division you gotta think about all the
numbers whereas in polynomial long
division all the really matters is the
leading term that's what really matters
so the first thing you say is well how
many ten squares if it just said cute
and the answer is it over so you're
right is it out there and then you say
well I multiply through now it gives me
said cubed minus four squared plus 13
said yes okay now what why did you next
I subtracted I already know I'm going at
nothing there when I do this subtraction
watch out for the double negative
well maybe get minus threes in sweat
right you're that now I actually don't
need to go any further I already have
all the information I want do you see
why I'm not just doing long division for
long division see what I'm really after
is this number here right I know I'm
going to get something like that I know
there's the remainder II though I don't
need to get all the way through as soon
as I've written this right I mean let's
just for the sake of it I'll finish it
off so you see I'm not like look doing
anything dangerous yeah I wanna subtract
that one that's
and they're not really down the -
they've done okay my next step again
because it's all about the leading time
I just said well how many dead sweat
it's been there and the answer is -
three
I can stop pranking in fact I can stop
as soon as I wrote that down this is not
just longer vision for long division say
I'm using it as a tool to get to this
number and they've already got it so
from there don't mock it it's not as
much work as you might have nation of
initially think about I can say
therefore this is the fact I'm a stump
use n equals now both from there and
from here what I want to finish that
good morning even though is this looks
simpler it's not the linear
factorization is it that's that's got a
quadratic factor in it so I just need to
come back to this slide that's the
linear factorization says that the one
to three to the effectors in it so that
will tie everything up in any book so
I've got Zen - the first rib that they
gave me
Zen - the conjugate of that room and
then - the ribbon I found either by
comparing coefficients or by going
through them on division okay I am going
to expect most people probably going to
look to this as a quick make quickly
because if you do it is faster but this
is not that long and one balloon is a
very versatile sort of
yeah
yeah yeah okay so you have to really kid
in fact I'm going to remember in a bit
you can always use like a mutation
results right if you know things about
the roots like okay I can say alpha
alpha bar and then there'll be another
one and then you've got all of the
coefficients this is not like a flight
animal find K type thing you can do it
all conclusively there you'd say okay
this summer verse is going to be
assembly this sort of thing so if I can
say yeah okay I've got 2 plus 3i plus 2
minus 3i which we know is going to be
very useful to us plus whatever that
third group is going to be it's going to
be 7 right - being on a that's a great
way to do it because you can see cancel
cancel 4 + 7 + 4 + 3 P okay which of
course we do which then puts us at the
same spot that we've waited so you can
see now that you know so much about
Colorado it is why people get them a lot
because there's so many patents option
one option two option three